Luke out Star Wars fans we're rapidly
approaching complete Star Wars
saturation it's getting to the point
where we're being forced into
participating for Alderaan reasons even
if you do think all this Star Wars stuff
is nothing more than a trap for
consumers you must admit that Google's
Star Wars promotion is pretty cool
Yoda be a fool to miss out as part of
its ongoing Star Wars Celebration google
has launched an excellent easter egg
themed around the upcoming sci-fi movie
go to google.com right now and search
for a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away to see the surprise this is just
one part of Google's partnership with
Disney to promote The Force awakens
beginning this week you can align with
the light or dark side choosing your
side which you can change at any time
will add a variety of Jedi or Sith
powered enhancements to your Google
experience YouTube's progress bars turn
into lightsabers appropriate to the site
you've picked complete with zoom noises
the tiny Google Maps Pegman will either
be a teeny weeny x-wing pilot or a
teeny-weeny stormtrooper google
translate now includes alien languages
and Gmail showcases Star Wars themed
backgrounds even Google calendars in on
it you'll find the force awakens
penciled in to your diary if it's not
already is it bad that this makes us
wish Google owned more things we'd love
to see the whole of Twitter choosing
between the dark and the light side
though I guess that's what Twitter is
anyway have you booked tickets to see
the force awakens or are you just gonna
x-wing it let us know in the comments
I'm Kate you can find me on twitter at
how not to draw and remember to keep it
gamespot.com for all your Star Wars news